hey what's up what did many younger
nates man check me out on the bootleg
care podcast stop playing man
yo it's the boulet calf show special
guest my bro man young and ace is here
jacksonville's finest here what's good
bro i feel like i
ain't seen you in a couple years man
glow up is real though
trust chess i ain't even been in atlanta
a minute too you trap it so bad out here
man it's crazy because uh
the last time i saw you i feel like it
was
a few months maybe six months after you
got shot yeah
probably so yeah it was it was um you
came through you freestyled you did your
thing
yeah i did yeah i did i think you had
like i think you were dropping the step
harder and yeah that's what's going on
yeah if i like
like 2019 early 2019 probably 2019 for
sure
yeah so you're here man and uh you know
the buzz is crazy
uh you're the jewelry is bigger
a lot more ice trust how you feeling man
how are you feeling right now
i'm good right now especially with my
album going crazy right now yeah
top 10 on apple pho then my first time
going top 10 for a week straight like
really it's going usually it's like what
happens like day one and then it'll fall
out right like day one day two day three
then it just go back to
seventeen eighteen right now i'm saying
trend like that but it's just going
crazy no
that's something like everybody's
starting to like
like really notice how raw i am you know
what i'm saying like
they're really starting to see the
talent for and like the story that i'm
telling like you know what i'm saying
like my sounding got way bigger
from weight in right i don't really like
like what it's called like mature
in my music facts you know what i'm
saying so they starting to just like
really like notice like damn he actually
you know what i'm saying mm-hmm [ __ ]
like that so i'm really feeling good i
i put everything into that album bro you
know what i'm saying give me give me
like the um
why the name why life of betrayal two
times i have a trail two times he
first my first project i came out with
like patreon at the first one right
after i got shot
so at the end this one right now this
life patrol two times it's really like
how life going
you know what i'm saying like i said
it's the biggest sound of me you know
what i'm saying so two times
that's my little brother who had passed
away that wasn't called right right
right so
everything two times now you know what
i'm saying so just stuff like that but
really like like betrayal like you know
say my whole life i remember trade you
know what i'm saying
so they all play a role in like my whole
life i've been i've been
off like you know what i'm saying like
struggling going through it
no hell you know what i'm saying so all
that i felt betrayed like
my whole life like but family friends
everybody who all left us
just empty-handed or just left us
struggling now you know i'm saying so
all that just play a role in it
yeah i mean you know you know it hasn't
been any secret recently
uh about jacksonville and everything
going on in jacksonville
i feel like when we first linked up
jacksonville was bubbling but
nationally it was really just uh you and
osiris oh yeah uh but now it's like
the hotbed of hip-hop right now yeah i
ain't gonna lie i'm really like
i'm [ __ ] with it like i look i love
to see like my whole city going crazy
like i never hated you know what i'm
saying
so my whole goal was for me to even to
get
get where i'm at and for to create
opportunities for them from you know
what i'm saying because no like i said
it was no opportunities there nobody
nobody never made it outside of
jacksonville right right right
so for me to get for me to get as big as
i like i am now it was on the right that
i
helped you know i'm saying everybody
want to come here but i'll go grab a
couple artists from jacksonville bring
them to one man we'll record
teach them the game let me teach them
what i know right i'm saying i'm going
to tell you what i know
and show them like show them the routes
like you feel me it's only it's not that
you do
to take it you know what i'm saying like
that yeah i mean you guys definitely got
it right now
uh you know what what what do you think
is like um
you know for you being kind of the face
of
uh i mean one of the faces of the city
obviously right like do you feel like
you have any sort of responsibility to
kind of uh
you know the generation that's coming
after you to kind of
you know what i'm saying like you you
low-key are like oh gee you you've been
active for like four or five years you
know what i'm saying
[Music]
should i feel me on on the album you got
uh g herbals on the album
[Music]
we just had him up here vaughn vaughn
all right i got
uh lucha shout out to lucci see it's
okay oh and i got
spinner bands right right of course of
course of course so but is it see it's
so crazy how my album played out you
know what i'm saying cuz like
i don't really like even do features for
you know what i'm saying so
i got uh see her heard about you know
going and spinning what spins you got
that was
groom spinning and uh
it's so crazy because that [ __ ] going
crazy i'm saying yeah no that's that's
crazy like two at two out of the i mean
two of the biggest features i mean
obviously vaughn's not here and and
and you know free luchi you know
hopefully he gets out um
yeah give me kind of like your take on
uh
why everything is so violent coming out
of your city right now
because i feel like you know i i it's
unfortunate because there's so much
talent coming out but i feel like
kind of like within the industry when we
think of jacksonville it's almost like
it feels like the new chicago
when it comes to the rap [ __ ] you know
what i'm saying it's just a lot of
just a lot of beef a lot of [ __ ] up
energy you know what i'm saying would it
why is that man uh i don't think it's
like uh you know it's real for sure like
no i'm saying but i don't
that's what people just only want to see
the bad you know so they only see the
bad
that's why that's why it's like the way
it is because they only want to see they
only see bad they don't like when you do
good
they don't go even with the blogs and
all that their own posts when everything
good like
when people be giving back or people do
all they only want to post negative so
that's why i get like this because
not before they got to do negative for
me for me to even be seen
you know what i'm saying right so that's
why it's like they ain't like it's
feminine
like yeah you know it's crazy it's crazy
because it is
good for business rap beef is good for
business that's all that's all that
people like to see their
attention but it's bad because [ __ ] be
real
it's people people lose their life
you've had family lose your life on the
other side people have lost their life
um and you know i had fulio up here
about a month ago i don't know if you
saw the interview
um but i you know i'd asked him
you know if he'd ever be open to talking
to you and and try i mean and i i'm not
a i'm not
anybody to tell anybody how to behave
when
life is lost you know what i'm saying at
the same time
and by the way i you know i i held him
on over the fire about the record he put
out
his response to your record because i
thought that that was not the
very low low class move to do what he
did you know what i'm saying
um but what what like is there
any sort of line in the sand that's like
that that is even they that
when it comes to this [ __ ] anymore cause
y'all really man
between who i smoke and in the response
it seems like all bets are off and i've
i mean i grew up listening to tupac do
hit him up and [ __ ] wasn't even as crazy
as what y'all are
talking about bro i don't really know
is there is there any like would you
ever be open to
having a discussion like you know what
i'm saying like i i ain't really
i don't know him like i've never seen a
man before right never i don't even know
you guys have never had any any
discussion no talks nothing i've never
seen none of these people before
it's like i say people see bad they want
this to see the bad bro
what is the thing is like you're gonna
keep on performing who i smoke because
it's one of the hardest hardest songs in
the man i don't get worried
you're getting paid to do the shows he's
getting played in clubs
and he's and he's getting the biggest
eyes he's ever seen off of this [ __ ]
that he put out
and it's like there's what's the
incentive to stop the
the the the violence you know what i'm
saying or or even just
i don't know man i mean i just feel like
i'll be irresponsible to see you up here
and
and not and not bring it up to you know
what i'm saying i don't know dude
[Music]
to foreign i don't know him at all
never seen him before in life never
we've never even seen each other
never seen none of them i don't ever see
nothing nobody know they don't even know
me
so that's what i say like i ain't
needing like
like i said brothers i'm to the money
like
i ain't i'm to the money when you uh
when you when you wrote the who i smoke
record
obviously first of all whose idea was
that
he's being crazy but he's a great artist
but he really hard hard
yeah for sure one thing about him bro
his work ethics craze through the roof
for sofa
no i mean obviously the uh the genius
idea
i for sure thought i was only gonna live
on youtube i was like there's no way
that this girl's clearing this record
this is okay
it's gonna be a youtube classic vanessa
she dope so
it's so crazy because i wasn't even
feeling like fun to get on the song for
real well i was gonna get on it
but like i said it was like it was
different like you know what i'm saying
and one thing about spinning he ain't
afraid to do something different you
know what i'm saying
walk to walk crazy with it too and going
you know what i'm saying
so they put it on we all in the studio
we just vibing so
he been standing for a couple days like
oh we can do this drill time for the
like you know what i'm saying so when
they put together he went in
then went in then when i went in i ain't
even mean to come like that like we
don't we don't sit there and write so we
just come on top of our head so
it's so crazy because i came it just who
i who
yeah but everybody knew it was gonna be
big like everybody knows that
everybody had already heard the song it
was like a little like a little viral
little title going on
in the studio like that so yeah i
already knew this
and you and you thought to yourself i'ma
say these names on this song
and this is a good idea
it works i mean obviously it's a hit
right for sure it's your biggest i mean
it's the biggest record you've been a
part of so far in your career
so yeah um man
vanessa carlton clearing the record was
that something that caught you by
surprise even
yeah kind it did because i ain't never
eating like i
i never thought we'd ever cross paths
one day
in life you know what i'm saying so we
just think of white chicks yeah it's a
crazy guy i talked to on the phone
i'm like man you you got some white
chicks
yeah she laughing we just laughing and
vibing and [ __ ] like that so it's just
like
it was really dope though for her to
even do that in the way she came out and
opened up you know what i'm saying so
i it all played it all played his role
and actually was a success
no for sure and you actually like had
some like uh conversations with her
yeah she's she's solid yeah she's solid
for sure
she's really real solid she cool she be
in her own world like you know what i'm
saying so she
she thought yeah from without from what
for what i uh
yeah i think if anybody were to guess
like a relationship that would transpire
in music uh last on my guesses would be
young and ace and vanessa carlton
for sure having a friend supposed to be
doing a tour or something [ __ ] like uh
pilot i think another yell she told me
come on if you if you
open up on a vanessa carlson tour my my
whole world has exploded
i can't wait to see i already told you i
was gonna do it so but you know so crazy
because i really i was telling my label
and stuff
i really wanted to like like
do like her doing piano like and
what it's called like a live like
performance thing right and i'm saying i
want to do hell and compensate her part
well all that just rap like you know
what i'm saying dude everybody going to
do their own part
and she's just doing acapella on the
computer straight strip down piano gonna
be so
vile bro it was when it went too crazy
yeah
that's crazy um with everything that's
going on you guys are kind of like the
hot
hot topic of the internet there's like
documentaries about you and what's
happened to your family and
you know your brothers that have been
been been taken and
you know there's like one that's got
like five million views on youtube it's
it's like it's like a whole you know
you've probably seen it yeah i ran
across it but
see all this [ __ ] just be like i say it
just be for the hype you know what i'm
saying
so i don't really like they just be
putting stuff together they'd be outside
people looking in
i was gonna say but like is that is that
like an interesting position to be in
where you're like there's like
youtubers making full-fledged 30-minute
documentaries about your
trauma your life you know what i'm
saying it's really bad
i don't really like when they do stuff
like that because now i make the
industry look at me a certain way so not
they feel like they can't have me in
certain places
because of violence you know what i'm
saying and then what i'm trying to give
out like you feel i'm saying
that's like you feel me i'm wrong mature
i'm wrong so i'm trying to really like
listen
listen let's get you feel me yeah i want
this money let's let's
i want greatness i want grammys and i
want all this see all that you can't get
all that when you got violence with
when you got when you're surrounded by
violence [ __ ] they don't want that
yeah
to be fair your biggest song is an
extremely
negative diss record for sure it's it's
one of the most ruthless dis records in
hip-hop history
for sure it's top two the other one's
the other guy's one that he put out
so like it's crazy like to be fair do
you think like like when you say like
if people look at you and they think of
that like are they wrong to think of
that right now
because that's kind of like that's
that's their fault that's fair
because they don't they don't like they
just see that one record and then i got
so much music like no you got catalog
you know what i'm saying so it's i got
so much great music for sure
stuff that i've not been stood up 10
hours a day every day and i've been
saying like you you're not new
this is not like you didn't just come on
the scene you've been doing your thing
you've been putting that
just be dissing i don't know that i
ain't even me to even do that i only
like stuff
i don't like i said i don't even like
the internet i don't even play the
internet role i only like going back and
forth
with people right right right this ain't
this hanging in that field i'm saying
so i'd just be what do you think is the
biggest misconception about young
ace
yeah but here it's a lot of [ __ ] that
people be missing
like what they want misunderstood you
know what i'm saying
like i be feeling like people be trying
to block me out because of certain [ __ ]
like if i'm saying
i'm gonna go for real for sure like you
know what i'm saying like she's so crazy
because my life
is real life so that's why everybody
grabbing gravitating toward this
this like this real life this thing he
ain't just you know what i'm saying
so that's what making it like you know
i'm saying the way they shaking it up
like my baby yeah you're good bray's
shaking
like shaking stuff up i'm underrated i'm
gonna go for sure
i'll be i'm trying to open everybody's
eyes and now you just i need people to
open their eyes and really see what's
going on
but really i really been trying to help
people mm-hmm
that's that's one thing about me i'm i'm
always helpful i've always been helpful
even when nobody helped me i want to see
everybody win i ain't no
crap you know what i'm saying see my
city full of crabs in the pot i ain't
the crowd
i never got in that part with crabs was
you know what i'm saying so
just sit like that like one thing they
i want the best for everybody hey what
up man how to interrupt the bullet cab
podcast to tell you about our good
friends
at odd socks all right yo shout out to
them for
sponsoring the podcast but also we're
being such a fire company
and they just introduced their draws
that's right odd socks now got your
boxer briefs
on deck some tapatio joints and then of
course they got the best socks in the
game look at these stone cold socks
look at these two i mean look i love
froot loops but i love these froot loops
socks these are fire i'm taking those
for myself
they got all the licenses breaking bad
mac dre
odb wwe street fighter whatever you want
they got
including these draws i love these draws
i got some on right now
so listen tap in with odd socks go to
oddssocksofficial.com
use the keyword bootleg cab and you will
save 20
off at checkout so oddssocksofficial.com
keyword bootleg kev
save 20 to check out thank me later is
it still true that
in jacksonville you can't perform yeah
man they don't even let
if i go out there right now they're
going blitz police on blitzing so the
cops are just on your head out there i
ain't worried about no [ __ ] no people
no
no i ain't worried about none of that
it's the police yeah yeah
nah for sure man and i'm police a kid
man
i mean look i you know when it comes to
just like
the cops and you know we've seen so many
examples of like you know
they're out for for rappers right i mean
i mean look at you look at what happened
with pooh scheisse they i don't know if
you heard but they
they match the dollar bill from his
instagram the serial number on the
dollar bill and stuff like that see
to the scene of a shooting where the the
money came out the truck
they literally took a picture from
instagram and they lined up the serial
number
from the bills like that he hit it bro
that [ __ ] that [ __ ] that's the kind of
[ __ ] they're doing mm-hmm
so you got to be really careful these
[ __ ] ain't playing bro
i'd be out the way i'm not the way so
you don't even live in jacksonville at
this point no i moved i've been moving
jasper they've been made me move from
out of there
that's good that's and that's and it's
so crazy now i look back on it see like
like i said
mature so i'm me growing up i look back
and i say
see there's a reason they got me from
out of there it's a good thing because
who would tend to probably be dead in
jail right now that's fair
because the way out the type person i'm
is that like
i can move by myself like i'm type
person like
if if they want to came here i would've
just came by myself right i think the
last time i saw you you you weren't real
deep i think you made it had one one two
people would choose what i'm saying i
don't even beat you and that
you got your family with you yeah that's
my little brother yeah he's still high
school i just want to show him
l.a what i'm saying i've been wanting to
show him like different stuff like
and i'm gonna be like i can't even watch
many people like that i can't watch a
thousand people around
right right most people do it for the
look yeah i just you know i think that
like
i the you know i think the one the one
thing i told like shipes and whole van
when i first met you was like
yo he's he's like got a good head on his
shoulders you know
you're not you're not like a stupid
ignorant kid you know what i'm saying
and i just i don't want to see like i
don't want to wake up one day and open
up my phone
and it'd be like young and ace got shot
yeah for silver show because we see i do
this shit's happening so much or i'll
interview somebody
and they die
yo bro like this [ __ ] is real dawg like
you know what i'm saying and that's why
you know
i just like i definitely know i
definitely know it's real that i said
i've been shot
a lot no i know and you know you've lost
family members yeah so you know what i'm
saying
i already know what what life is like i
know what's like what's going on you
know what i'm saying
and you got kids right no you don't got
kids well that's good god
you know that's i mean you know so you
out here then
[Laughter]
[Music]
you got your brothers to take care of
yeah for sure you know what i'm saying i
got my girl
too chloe got my mom i got a whole
family life for sure right
how's mom like when my like how what was
what was your mom's
first impression when she saw who i
smoked
my mom my best friend she loved that
song i'm gonna love this one she had
played it all day my mom loved all my
music
the video was that i think the video was
like the the icing
like like the icing on the cake because
it was just like these guys are on a
golf course
so crazy ridiculous that video puzzle
band he puts one it puts one from the
golf course to a house
no y'all did it the right way and it
just went crazy i just
i already knew i was gonna do it like
you got it everybody i already said like
we all knew it
but like they don't see they knew it's
gonna be bad but they know it's gonna be
this big
mm-hmm i knew it was gonna get this big
because i like i say i've already been
so i know what
like i know what people want i know what
they you know i'm saying
see the people be want stuff like that
for me right but i'm not giving
i don't like giving them that type of
[ __ ] you know what i'm saying see but
like i said bro better my momma though
i'm a little i want music like
like my life betrayal i betrayed two
times she
she played all day like did your mom
ever tell you like i didn't like this
[ __ ] that [ __ ] wasn't it
i like the [ __ ] you said on this oh man
never told me never
she just did i mean even when i get
talking about her owner she never told
me that because she know
all this [ __ ] you're trying your story
man do you know what's your favorite
song on the new album
man like a chair two-time and my
favorite
every song one that's so crazy bro i
promise
it's probably my is your best album
best album you know what i'm saying so
it's so crazy so
i look i actually love every song on the
out
but i love dr chow because my mama loved
that
the most she loved giving me not too
giving up for giving up gonna be so big
like two years from now it's gonna be so
big i just
i'll be trying to tell everybody that
but two years not gonna be so big it's
already
it's already my fast growing uh song on
youtube right now
i'm saying it's the second fastest this
show i'm saying besides who i smoke
of course of course see but dr chow
that's too crazy um
like when it's all said and done man
like do you ever think about like what
young and ace's legacy is going to be in
10 years in the rap game
[ __ ] the streets i mean the rap game you
know what i'm saying see it's so crazy
because i can't even see 10 years man i
still be trying to get through the day
that's fair man that's that's why i
don't really be bobby steps ahead don't
get me wrong i'll be steps ahead
i'm saying hope for best prepared for
the worst though you know what i'm
saying so i'll i'd be
i don't need to see 10 years right now i
want some more let's get let's get this
[ __ ] down today
you know what i'm saying that's the type
of mindset i got let's get this done
today
then when we went tomorrow here then we
know what's going on you know what i'm
saying
[ __ ] like that um
is who i smoke's gotta be close to going
gold right yeah it's approaching gold
that's your first plaque right no you
have another oh no you already have a
plaque i've seen you post the plaque
before i got a plaque i got a
plaque uh with jd young actually uh oh
what it's called what that song called
yo the op smoking music out of
jacksonville at an all-time high
yo when i when i had the other guy here
he said in jacksonville we make op
killin music that's the genre of rap we
make do you agree with that
yeah because that seems to be like i
mean [ __ ] man
it's like that and yk osiris
it's like it's like one extreme and then
the other extreme
exactly it's so crazy now i say that and
they don't begin like that because they
know
like the whole city know that's what the
world wants so they feel that's what
they got to do to blow you know it's
like they're leaning into it because
they feel like that's what that's what
that's what will put them on
and that's on people people they want to
see bad you know what i'm saying that
and that's so crazy how the world is
like they all be trying to tell you like
oh you need to do this and do that but
then when you do this and do that they
don't show no
yeah i'm sure no attention this might be
the best song this might be well
this song will probably way wrong in
this song but y'all see this because
it's just negative the controversy the
negativity so why wouldn't you
yeah you feel like you're almost
incentivized to lean into that [ __ ]
i make real music have you had to um cut
anybody out of your team
over the last like 12 months because i
feel like people
a lot i always is that hard to do
because y'all know get from around me
because i feel like you know
i ain't gonna lie i'm a boy scene i see
how hard because because it's actually
for people that
i'm genuine like i give people chance
out of chance
chance out the chance and they just
continuously [ __ ] it up
so are you on it certain people got so
many amount of times like you might got
three times he might got four he might
got eight
yep you know what i'm saying you might
just got one yep yep yep
and it should be like the type of love
that i have for certain people you know
what i'm saying
so it'd be it'd be it'd be hard
sometimes like it'd be hard but
some people just gotta let go for the
better hey that's real
that's what i would say man i think like
you got a long career ahead of you
if you if you and i and i know it's it's
hard to
not lean into the [ __ ] because the
[ __ ] is what's
helping get you booked at these shows
and but like you have it's about that
longevity yeah
and guess what if you ain't here to
appreciate
what you're building then none of this
[ __ ] matters for so you know what i'm
saying like the shows none of the bags
you're getting right now
none of that [ __ ] matters so what you
said is some real [ __ ] like
it's hard i'm sure for you your city
just
kids coming up cause they see what's
getting attention out of jacksonville
and they're like yo this is what this is
what people want out of our city
definitely you know what i'm saying so
i don't want that to be the reason
though bri phone sound like like even
for people who
like see the internet play so much of a
powerful game right it does man
like order for you to like sell hell or
or
clothes or shoes or anything you want to
be basketball player athlete anything
the internet player rolling so some
people got to do publicity stunts for
them to get what they
mean why'd you say this man you're a
very talented kid you make great music
outside of
you know the diss [ __ ] and uh you know
if there's anybody in your ear telling
you to do more of that [ __ ]
get him the [ __ ] up out of your team hey
you know it's so crazy everybody
everybody around me don't they didn't
like everybody around me don't even like
when i do [ __ ] out there
i mean because they probably care about
you bro and they they just know
something they know they ain't
see i don't win from there because i'm
already right here so people who down
here and i get to bring
if i get talking about them then it's
like i ain't i ain't win i'm not gaining
that from that
other people they don't gain from me
because i'm because i'm like i said i'm
gonna be bigger
see but ain't what it is like yeah if
you got people who
benefit off you financially telling you
hey we don't like it when you do this
[ __ ] then they're real ones
because it's in their best interest to
just keep telling you to do the [ __ ]
because it means more money for
everybody
so you know what i'm saying are you
going to be doing uh you know now that
kovitz
[ __ ] gone well it's not gone did you
ever catch covets yeah no
i had that [ __ ] yeah i ain't having
coconut you get the vaccine
yeah no i ain't no i don't let people
touch on you no vaccine for young
ace none of that i don't i don't even be
around people to even catch covert
that's fair um are you going to be doing
any tours though since are you going to
be doing the tour thing see what i'm
saying we just come out of the tour
so i'm waiting to see you figure out all
that stuff right now vanessa carlton
actually does a tour and brings
first of all that would be [ __ ]
insane they're gonna be dope that would
be crazy i bring everybody out that too
yeah that would be i don't even know if
that would
uh that backstage dynamic of that term
you have you and your people and then
it's vanessa carlton and like
that [ __ ] i don't i'd be uh what about
just like what are you doing with your
bread man you're investing you getting
into any sort of like
you know crazy because i'm in the middle
of trying to start this uh it's
a truck company so you're getting to the
trucking game yeah i'm trying to i'm i'm
just one step away from finalizing
everything you know what i'm saying
that's smart man my boy does that
like uh real estate real estate and hey
that trucking business is
money though oh and then dogs okay you
start breeding dogs what kind of dogs
are they uh frenchies yeah french
bulldogs um
okay okay who what made you want to get
into the trucking game because that's
like a
that's like a not the most glamorous
like
[ __ ] but there's some real money in that
bro it's so crazy because i'm one day on
my uh i'm not
i'm in the main bat i mean i got me back
so yeah
my tire gets on flat so i call the tow
truck
tow truck company i'm like hey uh y'all
gonna get me like you feeling saying i'm
tired
so they like i will shout like i'm gonna
call about 10 trucks
right it took them four hours to come so
now i'm on that argument now
but it's so crazy because my whole time
thing i'm like i'm gonna get i'm gonna
get my own tow truck company i'm gonna
get my
and from right now i just thought about
it right now but then i got people so i
started reading into it looking into it
and i got deep i'm like hold on
i'm gonna do the box trucks i'll just
like you know what i'm saying
yeah you really get that truck [ __ ] you
get the routes popping you hire you a
driver or two
and you get this [ __ ] booming man like
10 trucks just go crazy
oh yeah nah that's smart bro most
rappers ain't thinking like you buddy i
promise you that
you better open that yet yeah i mean
[ __ ] i mean you did put a lot of money
on that on that neck of yours though oh
yeah yeah
that's a lot of ice bruh it's a little
slightly it's just something slight
what is that what what kind of watch is
that cardio oh yeah that's actually not
so crazy my boy vaughn had told me get
this watch
a word i'm gonna get an ap he like man
get caught yeah man nobody ain't got
what
that is some real [ __ ] nobody's got the
cardigan everyone's got the ap or the
rolex
this is like last this is early last
early last show and it's right for my
birthday and i'm like oh
i'm not bro you know what i'm saying we
should be telling each other about the
game like bro get me an ap
that shit's unique in the rap game
nobody's got a cartier everyone's got
that or the
or the uh patek um
what was your relationship like with
vaughn man i'm a boy for sure
like i don't really violent people right
he was one of the ones i bought but for
real like outside of music
definitely you know what i'm saying we
talk about everything together i'm about
to show
how did you guys initially link up like
what was that it's so crazy bro
because i ain't even know who he was at
first i had
i had to show up or dirk dirk you know
not saying tink and all them
like virginia so i'm walking past them
like i said i won't even
like fit me so i'm walking past him he's
like what's up ace
but i ain't really him i just walk right
past right right
you know everybody around me like kicks
on all them boy they like whatever
like whatever that's why i go back over
there you know what i'm saying my
brother fought with y'all foolish
yeah that moment what's up you guys like
yo look
now i'm saying we said a few words at
that night but
not too much not to be like friends but
we're just cool like
over time over that time we just like
just talking like you know what i'm
saying not too much of sliding up on
each other
like and one day he got on he got him uh
and come on
and i came today like pull up i pulled
up on from that day
it was something probably right before
that too that means like i'm gonna pull
up touch it but it was like from that
day right there it was just over it like
that's my boy
and just went for i was just out for
like five six hours oh wow
just surviving you're gonna anchor them
on the two so you can't go you can't
move around
i'm just every time not every time i
came today i was just with him yeah
yeah like bro come today come today and
then he'd come well i'm at now
you know what i'm saying just went from
there miami where everyone was going
was just linking up your time what was
it like uh you know obviously
finding out you know about his loss man
it was it was you know it was
unfortunate because we actually got
we saw what happened there's video of it
you know what i'm saying
[ __ ] up i ain't going and i ain't been
[ __ ] like that [ __ ] up like that for
i mean you've been through a long time
yeah you've had your brothers you know
what i mean like
yeah and she ain't gonna [ __ ] me because
i thought one and be feeling like
airtime [ __ ] somebody some [ __ ] like
that
like yeah or something she like that
happened so i'd be trying to buy that
won't really be getting into
like relationships you said uh that you
were not around enough people to catch
covet
so i'm assuming you stay up out the way
exactly
fond died beefing with a guy
not even in his own city with another
guy who
ain't from his city either some real rap
[ __ ] really some internet [ __ ] right
and like did that kind of like does that
kind of like
motivate you to move different when you
when you saw what happened to him
because this
you know that's just crazy to think he
died in atlanta he's from chicago
beefing with the dude from baton rouge
like it's it's it's
you know what i'm saying it's like it's
so unknown it's just wilder [ __ ] to me
bro like oh that's
crazy discreet stuff no i'm saying so
but does that kind of like motivate you
just kind of just stay out the way like
y'all you hitting the club are you
staying home like go to the club
you just stay home i don't know there's
no reason why i can pay you i ain't
going to work yeah you go get your bag
otherwise you you're at the credit
show i'll be i'll be vibing i'll be i'll
be i'll be chilling i don't really like
i don't even like dealing with people
only be when kind of recording songs
i never even recorded songs in the
studio other rappers except like
vaughn and jd young gang proud who i
just did something with lil yachty
nice that's probably the only people
i've ever been in the studio with how
was
how was uh being in the studio with a
little yachty
[Laughter]
i like i [ __ ] the way he is because he
kicked off a lot of this internet [ __ ]
for a lot of artists man everything he
do he just
he got like people around they working
like no he's smart notice that when i
when i went
with him i noticed everybody in there
was doing something right
right yeah everybody working so here
everybody working like that that's it
crazy
a smart hey you got to have people
around you you got to have they got to
have a role they got to do something
you know some [ __ ] going on everybody's
going to hang out for the free food and
the free trips but yeah
i need you to sit out and sell this
merch at this table you know what i'm
saying
oh yeah yeah i'm telling you everybody
from the cameraman somebody doing
computers somebody was doing it doing so
that's crazy or something oh what is
here
well what's what's uh the album is out
what's next for you though bro
i got two more albums probably i'm
trying to draw two more albums for the
end of the show
okay i'm trying to go crazy i just i
need to
i just want to like i gotta say i want
to like
damn something different you know what
i'm saying would you do like a
compilation with with the crew like
you know what i'm saying like i joined
yeah
just you know yeah that that was that
that was that was part of those
that wasn't though but i got some i'm
trying to do like my little chloe
mistake my chloe album
and uh step harder okay
so it's gonna be it's gonna be a a busy
rest of the year for you
yeah for sure i got i got so many news i
got so many i got so many music i can
release the song every day for the next
three years
damn i record so much that's some tupac
[ __ ] bro
[Music]
that's a lot of music bro i got a lot of
[ __ ] to talk about
listen man i want to see you end up like
tupac so do me a favor bro
just you know i ain't going to tell you
how to handle your personal business but
you know i would love to see you uh
squash whatever you got going on and you
know with the fulio guy you know what
i'm saying
and and by the way i ain't nobody for
you to give a [ __ ] about i'm just
look man you're a good kid and uh i
think you know you gotta you got a long
career ahead of you bro
appreciate that so yo the album is out
go [ __ ] with it two times
and yo hopefully we see you on tour of
vanessa carlton i would
i would i would spend 500 on a ticket to
that show
i would actually spend like a thousand
dollars just to hang out backstage
just to see what backstage was like at
the vanessa carlton young and ace tour
i better go too crazy for sure so yeah
for sure yeah all right my g well thank
you for pulling up brother
perfect